alt und dafür relativ hoch aber so
extrem schmales fenster dann haben wir
es endlich raus bekommen haben dass auf
die seite gelegt und dann bin ich mit
meinem meter 90 durch dieses winzige
toilettenfenster chens st josefs kids
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
video in dem sich heute zwei geschichten
erzählen möchte eine geschichte von
einem sehr sehr tollpatschig menschen
und die andere geschichte davon wie
diese selber tollpatschige mensch ich
zum einbrecher wurde und zwar gestern
ich bin tatsächlich eingebrochen
aber okay wie das passieren konnte er
sich gleich so erst mal wenn wir uns ein
bisschen equipment und ich fange mal an
mit der geschichte von der
tollpatschigkeit so ich habe diese
geschichte hier gestern euch schon mal
erzählt beziehungsweise schon mal auf
video aufgenommen wie ich sie erzähle
und dann wollte ich die heute im
aufschneiden und dachte mir so ja mach
ein bisschen platz weil meine eine
festplatte ziemlich voll gefüllt ist
manche können sich vielleicht schon
denken wohin die reise geht jetzt gerade
mit dieser geschichte und ich dachte mir
so ja da ist auch ein desktop
audiodateien die kannst du weghauen die
brauchst du nicht so ich löschte ihn in
den papierkorb also wenn man dateien bei
wurden aus deutschland erstmal im
papierkorb
dann lasse ich sie nochmals den
papierkorb browser dass sie wirklich weg
sind und dann fällt mir auf dass diese
datei nicht gerade eben gelöscht habe
einfach die audiospur war die ich würde
es heute gewitter brauche und ich raste
innerlich so übertrieben die aus ich
hasse sowas wenn irgendein estate
aufgrund eines technischen fehlers eine
aufnahme irgendwie geigt ist es so
schwimmen
aber hey die einzige alternative war
jetzt dann nachdem ich die audiospur
gelöscht ob also meine mikrofon aufnahme
weg war den ganzen quatsch nochmal
aufzunehmen hier übrigens erst regel
chains als legitim und erlaubt so und
jetzt sitze ich wieder hier an dem tag
an dem ich eigentlich nach berlin
umziehen sollte und wollte und niemand
die geschichte nochmal auf das verzögert
den ganzen spaß ziemlich alter passt was
gibt der mich für hits bitte wo lotte
hier sec
geht er oder geht glaubt ja okay das war
die erste geschichte von der tätigkeit
jetzt gehen wir weiter zur zweiten vom
einbruch dazu eine sache vorweg ist ein
item hauptkommissar thomas rhein
hopp hopp hopp hopp ich habe einen
nachbarn beziehe seine ganze familie
hier die ihr neben uns wohnt und diese
familie beziehungsweise der
familienvater die sind eben ein bisschen
vergesslich und die sperren sich öfters
mal aus in den letzten tagen artet das
wirklich aus mit dem aussperren
und sie haben sich vorvorgestern das
vorletzte mal ausgesperrt also
vorvorgestern vor drei tagen ist das
vorletzte mal ausgesperrt und dann
gestern schon wieder das heißt innerhalb
von zwei tagen zwei mal ausgesperrt also
eine ganze familie haben mindestens zwei
personen schlüssel aber die vergessen so
scheinbar auch immer wieder ja gut beim
ersten mal haben sie dann irgendwie drei
stunden herumgewerkelt haben da ein
schlüsseldienst kommen lassen als es
nicht geschafft haben selbst anzukommen
beim zweiten mal innerhalb von zwei
tagen dachten sie sich so ja kein bock
ist ein schlüsseldienst gerufen
wir fragen wir unser nachbarn und der
nachbar bin ich und ich habe gesagt ja
gleich ich helfe euch natürlich
und dann standen wir da und haben
versucht irgendwie rein zu kommen und
ich schaue mir so ich habe mich ein
bisschen um schauen wir mal so die bude
an der zeit mich so okay was kann man
hier machen und dann dachte ich mir okay
da oben ist ein fenster es ist zwar
relativ hoch so ungefähr 1 34 metern
höhe
aber es ist ein doppelfenster dass eine
fenster gekippt und wenn man ein
doppelfenster hat bei dem beide ein
fenster gekippt ist kann man zumindest
theoretisch durch das eine fenster
reingreifen das gekippt ist
an den griff des anderen fans ist
eingriffes anderen fensters umlegen und
das andere fenster dann aufdrücken
so ich hoffe ihr versteht was ich meine
das habe ich schon mal so bei uns
gemacht bin so mal eingestehen als nicht
mal den schlüssel vergessen hatte also
dachte ich mir okay das kann vielleicht
genauso auch bei den nachbarn machen
also was machen wir das fenster war wie
gesagt mit drei metern höhe
die frage war wie kommt man dahin sodann
habe ich erst mal eine leiter geholt
eine kleine ader leiter dichter hatte
also ich hab ja nicht geholt sondern
irgendwann hat sie dahin gebracht habe
der nachbar selbst
mein lieber diese leiter ist ungefähr
ein meter fünfzig hoch das fenster ist
sind des nee das war keine drei meter
mehr
das waren viereinhalb meter die leicht
das 150 hoch viereinhalb meter höhe
da komme ich nicht hin sodann haben uns
überlegt wie kommen wir dann doch dahin
wir haben das so eine leiter auf dem
dachboden dann habe ich mir gedacht okay
dann haben wir die seite vom dachboden
also habe ich die aluleiter genommen um
die große holzleiter vom dachboden zu
holen und die typ nicht richtig dreckig
abzustauben
oder die das mädel sie ist einfach
einfach hanna okay je einfacher
wir gehen direkt in die nächste runde
sodann habe ich die leiter vom dachboden
geholt wissen übrigens keine kuh ist und
will dann rüber zum nachbarn hat mir das
ganze angeschaut die leiter an die wand
gestellt und dann erst mal gemerkt dass
die leute ein bisschen kurz ist das
fenster war wie gesagt in vielen metern
höhe die leiter war ungefähr drei meter
hoch also so oder so auf jeden fall war
die leider viel zu kurz eigentlich
eigentlich müsste noch ein bisschen
höher gewesen sein das fenster weil ich
bin auch 1 90 groß und ich kam auf jeden
fall bei weitem nicht ans fenster dran
also mussten wir die leiter nicht jeder
normale mensch macht so schräg gegen die
wand stellen sondern quasi parallel zur
wand so senkrecht hoch was die leute
extrem kippelig gemacht hat aber was
aber machen bin ich halt auf diese
extrem kipling leiter da hoch habe es
auch irgendwie geschafft denn da hoch zu
kommen kam dann oben an dachte mir so
unendlich ist der käse hier mal erledigt
wir können jetzt helfen wir können
reingehen aufmachen alles gut
weit gefehlt es war dann einfach so dass
ich oben ankam durchs fenster geschaut
und gesehen habe dass das das zweite
fenster also ein zwar gekippt und ich
wollte durch reich und das andere auf
machen aber das andere fenster hatte
einfach kein griff also hat das alles
nichts gebracht alles umsonst die ganze
aktion mit der leiter das hochklettern
das eigene leben zu riskieren war
einfach vollkommen umsonst bisschen
scheiße bisschen ärgerlich aber da muss
man eine andere lösung finden und habe
von dem plan abgelassen um die leiter
wieder weg gebracht und dann haben wir
uns gedacht ja okay wir kommen so nicht
rein wir müssen jetzt irgendwas
beschädigen
und dann haben uns gedacht okay an der
vorderseite ist ein fenster an der
toilette vielleicht probiert es mal
damit gesagt getan
wir sind einfache und einem
toilettenfenster zu schaffen wo bitte
box mir nicht ich will nicht sterben ich
will eigentlich die aggies anziehen ganz
ehrlich zeigt sehr schön
dann fange an einem toilettenfenster zu
werke da war ich schon nicht mehr
alleine sondern wir hatten dann noch den
hausmeister zur hilfe ich hätte ganz
unten abgestützt und dann stand ich mit
diesem hausmeister da und wir haben auch
locker will nochmal eine
dreiviertelstunde stunde gebraucht an
diesem fenster rumgeschraubt umgebogen
das eingedrückt schrauben gelöst und
dann nach zwei stunden und nach dem
einen oder anderen gewaltsam versucht
das fenster raus zu brechen ist es dann
auch tatsächlich rausgebrochen also
irgendwie schienen beschädigt das
fenster selbst war zwar noch intakt aber
die schienen und die schrauben ein
kompletter marschen verbogen haben wir
dann geschafft dieses toilettenfenster
das war wirklich klein rauszubekommen
also das war so vielleicht den robot
dance so breit und dafür relativ hoch
aber extrem schmales fenster brach dann
haben wir es endlich raus bekommen haben
dass auf die seite gelegt und dann bin
ich mit meinem meter 90 durch dieses
winzige toiletten fensterchen und es ist
wirklich winzig gestiegen
dann innen auf die toilette gestellt die
direkt am fenster war und habe mich dann
quasi dann aus der toilette raus zur
haustür geschlichen hatte und dass das
allerbeste was habe ich noch gar nicht
erzählt das allerbeste war während wir
dann am fenster versucht haben rum zu
werkeln gingen einfach die alarmanlage
am auto unseres nachbarn los weil der
hat halt ein cabrio mit offenem verdeck
also verdeckt war und sein sohn dar
eingesetzt und irgendwie hat dieser sohn
irgendwas gemacht was die alarmanlage
ausgelöst hat und gestorben bist so
schön hat die alarmanlage ausgelöst und
dann standen wir da und während der
gesamten zeit die wir unserem fenster zu
schaffen gemacht haben hat einfach die
alarmanlage dieses autos durchweg
gewimmelt also die ganze zeit wirklich
das beste ist mein nachbar konnte nichts
machen
weil er seinen autoschlüssel im haus
hatte und das er konnte ja nicht ins
haus weil sie sich ausgesperrt hat also
standen wir darum zehn mann um dieses
haus und alle nachbarn plötzlicher wie
bescheuert weil wir da allein schon rum
standen oder wie fenster raus brechen
da kommt noch dazu dass auf einmal die
alarmanlage aus übertrieben anfängt lärm
zu machen und eine alarmanlage ist
richtig laut von dem auto das auto stand
halt zwei meter davon entfernt so gut
das war noch erschwerend dazu werden wir
das fenster raus genommen haben
irgendwann ist dann geschafft fenster
raus ich steig toilettenfenster rein
macht die tür von innen auf mein nachbar
übertrieben froh als wirklich dabei im
himmel
ich habe noch nie so früh gesehen dass
er endlich die alarmanlage aus machen
konnte war so peinlich
verständlicherweise alter das ist
gestern passiert was heute passiert ich
zum ich kann jetzt das video für euch
ihr seht wahrscheinlich um 15 uhr das
war's von meiner seite ich würde mich
dann wieder mit dem nächsten video aus
berlin und mit livestreams haut rein
macht's gut und
natürlich und dann war hat sich
rausgestellt warum seid ihr alle so
scheiße weil das andere doppelfenster
bei denen einfach keinen grip hatte ich
so was hab ich auch noch nie gesehen
aber das andere doppelfenster hatte
einfach keinen griff ja ich will das
aufnehmen von am tag gibt euch doch nur
ein premium alter durch alle ohne witz